so gentle criminal is the second main
villain in season four and whilst he's
nowhere near as sadistic as overhaul he
still represents a massive threat to
world peace or at least the you a
cultural festival but if you think about
it they're kind of the same thing sort
of this video will break down his
backstory and his awesome quirk which
allowed him to go for Captain America on
a group of professional heroes so
starting with his backstory
gentles real name is Dan Jareau and he
is somehow only 32 years old when I
first saw this character I genuinely
assumed he was at least 55 when he was a
teenager
dan Jorah had dreams of becoming a hero
and attended a low-level hero school now
whilst he was there he was held back and
had to retake his second year having
already failed the provisional license
exam four times by that point four times
guys four times and when we check out
his latest stats from the ultra analysis
book you'll see that his intelligence is
rated a very unimpressive 2 out of 6 so
I guess it's not all that surprising but
despite that he has a very bright
personality with miryo levels of
optimism his ultimate aim was to be a
great enough hero to be written about in
the textbooks and that's essentially his
philosophy in a nutshell he's a guy who
wants to be remembered by future
generations and later his philosophy
evolves into wanting to inspire those
who feel left behind by society as well
now one day when he was leaving a cafe
gentle spotted a window cleaner falling
off a building and figured that his
quirk could help the guy and what's all
explain his quirk in a bit the main
point is that in trying to save this
person gentle got in the way of a hero
performing his duties which then led to
the man suffering severe injuries from
which he needed six months to recover
this is when his life began to fall
apart as he was charged with obstructing
public duties and thrown out of his
parents house hell he was even expelled
from school his initial acts of trying
to say this window cleaner is eerily
similar to how dec who rushed into
battle to save back ago and how koishi
rushed in to save pop step this is a guy
who just like them tried to save an
innocent person but unlike them gentle
had undesirable results that made his
life infinitely worse dan drew was
unlucky in a way that those two weren't
that's the only difference here and by
the way if you don't know who kawiti is
that I'd recommend checking out my
explanation video of my hero academia
vigilantes
after this one but moving on in the new
outro for season 4 we see a young gentle
at school with his friend
Takeshita now in the manga Takeshita was
a farmer year student who had offers
from several hero agencies and four
years after gentl was expelled he was
unemployed and saw his old school friend
patrolling the streets as a hero so
naturally as you see old friend you got
to say hi but to his surprise
Takeshita didn't even remember who he
was which is pretty crazy when you think
about it how do you forget someone
completely after only four years dude it
was at this moment that gentle realize
that his dreams of becoming a famous
hero was dead but if he couldn't be
remembered for that then he'd become
infamous instead searching through his
closet he found an old book could be
history of super villainy which serves
as an inspiration for what he was about
to become and I think what makes him
such an interesting villain is that he's
not motivated at all by money or
whatever else villains typically won
instead as he says here it's all about
exposure literally and because of that a
few years later gentle began uploading
videos on YouTube under the alias of
gentle criminal and doing so became the
first proper youtuber that we've heard
of in the Maya academia world however
his videos haven't really gone too viral
and if you notice here his comment
section has quite a few haters due to
his generally kind personality he's not
really someone who goes over the top in
committing acts of violence in fact he
rather wouldn't do it at all so when
people like all-4-one and stay in a
going viral for their actions people
don't really gravitate to gentles
content I guess because for a lack of a
better word is just a bit too gentle
but despite averaging about 10 views per
video gentle did manage to snag himself
a super fan in his sidekick la Brava
now the braava is someone who a certain
stage in her life was very depressed and
glued to her computer all day she
happened to stumble across gentles
channel and was inspired by his optimism
she tracked him down using how awesome
coding skills which gentl didn't find
creepy at all for some reason and in
fact he believed that they would make
the perfect team one last thing before
we move on to explaining his quirk it
wouldn't be a gentle criminal video if I
didn't mention the fact that this guy
loves t-t-to gentle criminal is what all
my Easter Deco just to give you a bit of
perspective in fact as I said just
before he ruined his life he was coming
out of the cafe like this guy can't be
stopped
but the way he paused the tea so
dramatically I think the ratio of tea
poured to tea that ends up in the cup is
probably not the best here anyway
gentle criminals quark has a lot of
different practical applications which
make him incredibly dangerous putting it
simply his quark is called elasticity
and it allows him to make anything he
touches stretchy and elastic so
basically like the inverse of Luffy from
one piece just to get your header on
this I'm gonna lay out a couple of
examples as to how he uses this quark so
firstly he can touch the ground and turn
it elastic and make it into a trampoline
this has the knock-on effects of sending
enemies flying into the air or because
he's mastered this power he can do the
exact same thing but instead sent
himself flying into the air in a
controlled manner another example would
be his gently rebound attack in which he
turns the air itself elastic this means
that anyone who runs into the air will
then be violently blasted in the other
direction and because air is usually
invisible is a great way to catch
enemies by surprise they'll literally
just run into it and they'll be thrown
back in the opposite direction the
dangerous thing about this quirk is that
he can manipulate virtually any
situation to his advantage
as I said he can turn the air elastic
which gives him a massive element of
surprise whilst also providing him with
a quick and easy method of escaping and
it also makes him pretty agile as well
as he can change direction fairly easily
some interesting things to note about
this quirk is that elasticity cannot be
canceled out by someone else's quirk
rather it can only disappear after a
period of time has passed so what I'm
saying is that once he's turned
something elastic nothing is going to
make that thing not elastic anymore you
just have to wait until the time has
passed now some people may perceive this
as a weakness as gentle doesn't exactly
control when the elasticity turns off
but given the way we've seen him use it
it doesn't really seem to be too much of
a drawback without getting in to plot
spoilers we've seen that gentle criminal
can make heavy objects elastic and then
use them in ways that would otherwise be
impossible when we go back to his stats
we see that besides having a 5 out of 6
for loving T he also has a 4 out of 6
face technique now I personally think
that his techniques should be higher
than this simply for the fact that if
you told me of this power I'd have
assumed that being able to turn the air
elastic would be the pinnacle of a quirk
like this it's super impressive that
gentle is able to do this
despite
never even finishing his formal hero
training remember he got expelled from
school in the second year and it wasn't
even that good of a school so to have
master disc work in this way and to be
able to take down multiple professional
heroes albeit average professional
heroes it's still super impressive when
we first saw his quirk in action
he turned the entire shop into what
looks like strawberry jelly
so yeah awesome quirk great technique
and ultimately he's gonna be a tough
tough villain to be defeated but anyway
guys that was my quick breakdown of
gentle criminals back story and his
quirk was this whole arc is dumb that
I'm gonna do a video looking forward
regarding certain characters involved in
this arc and if you like this video then
be sure to subscribe to the channel if
not to me then at least a gentle
criminal you owe him that much and be
sure to check out my latest theory video
where I deconstruct why Kirishima was in
fact the third user of one for all and
yes it makes sense but until next time
peace out